Hello Freak bitches.
You,
you worked at Salt Lake City,
right?
You might have,
yes.
Very good room on the a wiseguys.
Yeah.
I feel sorry for those people living in
Salt Lake City surrounded by all those
Mormons.
But it's beautiful there and Mormons
are nice if you're going to be around
religious nutters,
those are the people.
They're not mean people at all.
And all Donna's and Mormon.
She was.
Yes she was.
Was,
I mean she made me,
she was getting it.
No,
she probably,
she got,
I think they probably frowned
on that career decision.
Yeah.
I don't know why though.
She retired.
She did you say it like it was sadness,
like it was like a fucking
like babe Ruth retired.
I just haven't seen her in a while.
She did it either.
Yeah,
she made that.
She made it really,
I was luckiest girl in
the face of the earth.
You'll Jerry Cooper.
Fucking little,
little Gehrig for you.
I just wonder if she
can hold in turn still.
That's my only question I want to know.
Cause you know she was getting
baseball bats up her pussy.
She no upper ass baseball bat in our ass.
Yes.
That's cool.
Yeah,
there's a bit.
It's cool.
There's a video of it and
it's just so weird to watch.
It's like,
okay,
there you go out and they
don't piss all over the place.
I guess you can still.
Yeah,
but that's an asshole.
Her baseball bat winning or asshole.
Right.
Why does he say it holds in terms of like,
I guess those muscles re you know,
I guess,
but people do have problems.
People that like engage in
those activities really do
have problems stretching
out their,
their anus muscles.
I can fake it a little bit of a finger.
I can't tell you anything else.
I was dating this chick and uh,
her roommate had sex with her boyfriend
and he fucked her in the ass and uh,
her sphincter must've relaxed and she
shit on him while they were sleeping and
uh,
she shit the bed.
Oh Wow.
Shit on his Dick a little bit.
I don't know what.
Anyway,
he got up and you know,
it was like,
ah,
and the door slammed and the guy was
like standing in the hallway like this
I'm never forgets for fuck is,
you know the girl daddy
telling me what happened.
I'm like,
oh no shit in my mouth this year.
I told you that.
That's horrible.
I know what happened.
I was any girls out who was on ecstasy
for first time and then she shut my
mouth.
Cause you can feel it.
Yeah,
I you see that happening?
You don't want an accidental one.
That's not going to be a good one now.
It wasn't solid either.
I think it would be preferred,
a solid one.
And there's something about a solid one.
You're like,
hey,
this kind of looks like a fucking,
uh,
a smokestack.
There's something cool about it,
but it's not a subject I'm really into.
But there is a woman,
this German woman who does shit porn where
people shit on her and she's like the
queen of Shit Porn.
Don't ask me how.
I know that somebody posted it on my
message board and I've followed a fucking
all olink hole.
I went from Linkedin,
linkedin link till I got to her
site and watch some of her videos.
Your side.
Good egg.com
winner,
winner shit dinner.
It's just people shitting in her mouth
and she's covered in shit and it's she,
she eats it.
Yeah,
I mean it's making me swallow like,
no,
no.
Throwing up.
Oh,
it's making me a extra salivate
thinking about how disgusting it was.
But she was just eating logs that
were coming on his guys and guys,
ass guy,
shit's gotta be awful.
She says it's better.
She says it's Spicier,
cause many more meat.
And she was like explaining,
yeah,
I don't want to see what's a spicy log.
She's sitting there smoking cigarettes,
explaining in German why
she loves eating shit.
And then she,
she's got a like a
stomach of a Billy goat.
She never gets sick and she
feels herself up with shit.
And that's great.
You know.
But this is like,
the thing is there's so many types
of people out there in this world,
there's,
there's no normal,
there's like expectations of normality.
There's like a spectrum.
And they fought.
Most people fall into like this area,
but there's enough people out there
that like watching her eat shit that she
makes a living eating shit.
She has a website eating shit.
She's a member section.
She's famous for it.
Sherry interviewing her,
asking her questions.
They using a camera.
I mean it's like the whole deal.
It's like she's,
you know,
there's a,
it's not one person that
likes watching her eat shit.
There's a whole group.
Well the funny thing is too that like
when you think like the fact that she
smokes on top of it,
like if there's anything that can make
your breath worse than fucking eating
some fucking to some Nazis logs
and having a cigarette afterwards.
Imagine her burps.
The shit cigarettes.
Shit burps.
Yeah.
Craft services.
All fucking coffee and tuna salad.
Just really awful stuff.
Oh God.
I'm over here sneezes.
I am almost throwing up thinking
about this until I see her sneezes.
It's like I'm Brown.
Gray.
It's a little awful.
A spray like fiber.
If you had like a
cheesecloth in front of her,
you could see,
you know,
she can make a Rosh sharp.
Yeah.
Okay.